Let's get out of this country and be free
Looking at the wide world, I want to write how to convey that
If it's studying this time, it won't be difficult
Let's become strong and become pirates
like that  You don't have to tell
me I'm going to become a pirate Win, win, win,
and get the best reputation
That's all it takes to prove that I'm alive
No
matter how much you hate me, I'll
become a pirate and look back on you The
huge treasure face is the last islander who gets stabbed
How much
did you spend?
It's a bargain for a good boy,
go to the world, good, good
[music] The
king is
small
[music]
If you think you're going to say meow meow, it's a
business card that ends with a funny day Oh, what a funny day
I'm looking forward to your future